The European Space Agency has chosen the British paralympic sprinter, John McFall,...
...as the first astronaut with a disability to join the space training team.
He'll work with designers and engineers to see if it's possible for him to go into space.
Our science editor, Rebecca Morelle, reports.
It's the job of dreams with an office that's got spectacular views...
...offering an out of this world experience.
Many would love to be an astronaut, but very few make the cut.
Now in Paris, the European Space Agency has added...
...some new names to the roll of honor.
Selected from more than 22,000 applicants, this is the astronaut class of 2022.
But for the first time ESA is widening its pool of talent...
...by recruiting the first ever para-astronaut.
I think being an amputee, being an astronaut was never really on my radar.
John McFall is a paralympian sprinter.
His right leg was amputated above the knee after a motorbike accident.
He's been selected using exactly the same criteria as all European astronauts.
The only difference is he has a disability.
I thought I would have the skills and mix of skills and scientific background...
...that I could really help them answer this very aspirational question...
...of "Can we get someone with a physical disability into space,...
...to work in space safely?"
All astronauts have to undergo rigorous training.
Part of John's job will be to test how the kits like spacesuits and spacecraft...
...need to be adapted.
His selection doesn't mean he'll definitely get to go into space,...
...but he still wants to pave the way to make it happen.